like where sometimes I feel like
like I feel like a lot of times the way
that men act is in response to the women
because like if we required marriage
before sex like then men would wait like
they would marry us before that but it's
like it's like I feel like a lot of the
way that men like the trade cons will
like point at the men and be like you
act like this it's like well the women
started it
the problem is it's not it's not um it's
not men or women that are the problem
it's delusional people yeah it's not men
or women's do like like I don't care how
much you want to argue biology you can't
negotiate desire you can't argue biology
like like and people that we had this
girl on the show yesterday right like
she just had this belief of how things
should be